no worse always pay it forward that's my
motto
you know and cuz that any given moment
one of us could need a helping hand and
like now you to total strangers you know
we're short on cash and then someone
just steps out of the blue and up
something I don't know hey everybody its
charlie we got a whole bunch of DC news
to talk about the flash just confirmed
that Nora Allen is gonna be a series
regular meaning she'll be in most of the
episodes so some big upgrades for Nora
but we also got our first look at
cheetah on the set of Wonder Woman - and
we found out which version of the
character she's gonna be playing I know
there's a lot of theories about the
villain about Pedro Pascal playing one
of the other gods like Hades or Apollo
so we'll break all that stuff down if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a bunch of stuff
dropping this summer but there's also a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll be sure to name a new winner
at the end of this the big thing with
Norah is is that the season is built
around her mistake we all knew that she
was coming back but it was a question of
how many episodes she was gonna be in
and how they were gonna use her like
it's all in the execution they did a
good job of setting it up at the end of
season 4 but now they have to pay that
off like you actually have to do a
really good job of showing us what her
mistake was in making that really
interesting virtually everyone's in
agreement that her mistake has something
to do with her messing with the timeline
but not quite in the same way that Barry
did so we're calling it Noir a point or
a flash point 2.0 but it's not quite the
same type of problem but the flash
people already said that it's
specifically tied to each of the members
of team flash which is why she came back
to visit them like she visited Caitlin
she came back to the wedding to see
Barry and iris get married she met Cisco
and elongated man she even came back to
see Cecile and Joe so it's kind of a
Back to the Future style twist where
like she messes with things her little
future picture changes as she changes
things and she did something really bad
now it's so bad that she's come back to
get Barry's help because even though
they haven't been really clear on
exactly what her powers are what her
intelligence level is the way she came
across like what she was writing all
those Speed Force symbols was
early intelligent like even though she's
from the future this still seems like
pretty advanced stuff so what was berry
called the first time they introduced
him on arrow
the scientist she is probably just like
berry in that regard so the Apple does
not fall very far from the super smart
nerd tree actually that soundtrack that
they used when they introduced her on
screen that sounds exactly like when
they introduced berry that's called the
scientist that music cue was also one of
the reasons why I was convinced that she
was gonna be related to berry
it was just a question of how she was
gonna be related to him I've already
done a couple videos about what I think
Nora's mistake is and how it's tied to
the futures of the members of Team flash
like something very bad happens to
Cecile and Joe because she's like enjoy
the time you have while you have it she
pauses on that line like oh yeah
something definitely bad happens to them
in the future which is why she's taking
the risk of breaking the time line by
coming back to see them killer frost
obviously pretty easy slam dunk she
probably becomes a pretty bad villain in
the future which is why Nora doesn't
seem like she likes her that much but
the only thing we don't know is is what
Harrison wells is gonna be like which
version he's going to be because they
did imply it would be another one from
somewhere else in the multiverse that we
haven't seen before so the only thing I
will say about that is that it is not
going to be the new version of the
reverse-flash because he said that he
would have a different face like I just
did a video about reverse flash in
season 5 so we'll all really awesome
stuff but now you want to talk about
cheetah and Wonder Woman - there was a
set video with her doing wire work if
you didn't see it this is what it is
[Music]
I know it makes it seem like she's
riding in the invisible jet down the
freeway in Washington DC but that's just
them practicing wire work for her
jumping really fast or moving really
fast
remember the way Wonder Woman moves is a
little bit different from the way
Superman moves or the way the flash
moves there's a scene that they're
filming right now with all this chaos on
the freeway and she's obviously helping
out because she's Wonder Woman so she's
just moving around really fast trying to
save people and that's what the wires
are for but it gives you a much better
look at what her suit looks like when
she walks onto set I did a video about
that too like about how they really
cranked up the color on it so it's way
brighter way shinier it's just so the
colors pop that much more on-screen but
the really big deal is we got our very
first look at cheetah in the flesh like
literally in the flesh because she's not
wearing any kind of cheetah costume so
if you didn't know Kristen Wigg is
playing the cheetah character they
confirmed that she's playing the doctor
Barbara and Minerva version of the
character that's the third one and
obviously Kristen Wiig doesn't look
anything like a cheetah they might be
doing the new 52 or the rebirth origin
story for the character they sort of
reworked it again more recently during
rebirth where she starts out as Wonder
Woman's friend and fascinated by ancient
cultures she starts to learn how to
speak famous kheer she becomes an expert
on their history and then eventually
leads an expedition to Africa so she
falls prey to another tribe that's
trying to gain access to famous Kira so
like another villain acting on the
orders of Ares son so Ares like has his
own demigod son tries to turn dr.
Minerva into a demigod so that she can
gain access to that mascara so that Ares
son can gain access to that mascara
because remember it's still hidden from
the world so they turn Minerva into the
cheetah character but she gets this
crazy bloodlust and it goes off the
rails and she becomes this more tragic
version of the villain but I wouldn't be
surprised if they pull from all the
different comics eras but if you do want
to read Cheetahs backstory you can read
the original version it's Wonder Woman
vol 2 number 7 then more recently the
rebirth run because the rebirth version
involves Steve Trevor and they're using
him in the movie which is why I think
they might be leaning
weren't to the rebirth version of her
origin story but the other big rumor is
is about Pedro Pascal's character people
think that he's playing one of the other
gods like Hades or Apollo but also per
the rebirth story he could also be like
Wonder Woman be the son of one of the
gods and be a demigod with her level of
power that's still more of a rumor
because we haven't seen him doing
anything on set yet it'll probably be a
little while but if you see him on wires
flying around that you know that he's
probably also got God level power like
Wonder Woman too but I think what they
want to do for the sequel is sort of
avoid that third act problem that they
had when she started fighting Ares on
the strip and it turned into this big
morass of CG and everything kind of went
sideways they were some bits of that
that we're good but I think most people
agree that that's one of the weakest
parts of the film so I think that
they're trying to do better villains for
the sequel so you have that through
Cristiano wigs cheetah character more of
a tragic villain but remember it's
Wonder Woman there are gods and this so
there's also probably going to be some
God level stuff happening which might be
through the Pedro Pascal character so I
didn't say it but obviously it should go
without saying I do think the Kristen
Wiig will become the literal cheetah
character during the movie and she'll
look like comic book cheetah so she
starts out looking like a human but
through her origin story becomes imbued
with the cheetah power but what'll
happen is is they dropped a whole bunch
of footage so I have a Westworld finale
trailer that I do there's new ant-man
and the wasp footage and a whole bunch
of behind the scenes stuff I'll break
that down to maybe two more videos today
maybe just one anything I don't get to
tonight I'll just post tomorrow so no
worries but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner mister wicked
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for more new
flash season 5 and click here for that
Wonder Woman to suit teaser thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight